hello i'm chadwick boseman i'm the v10
young girl my name is Michael B Jordan
and we're doing a wired autocomplete who
is Black Panther the king and protector
of Wakanda for Captain America
historically throughout Marvel comic
history does Black Panther have
superpowers yes even beyond his suit
yeah he does it takes a heart shape
cuz I'm super strength a lot of cat-like
qualities pretty cool who is stronger
Black Panther aye Captain America huh
another great question hey Black Panther
they're the same but Black Panther edged
out Captain America almost every battle
that they had throughout Marvel history
so I'm gonna say Black Panther is
definitely stronger the Captain
America's shield is made out of
vibranium comes from Wakanda the whole
thing that's how they kind of connected
so yeah I'll say Black Panther for sure
who would win in a fight Black Panther
or Wolverine Black Panthers I mean move
mmm technically worried you know
maybe only because I know Wolverine will
kill somebody in a heartbeat Black
Panther might take a little bit longer
for him to get there and we'll probably
get the fight over like real quick so I
think that's more of a personality thing
rather than nobility then we're gonna
regenerate so be pretty difficult to
kill out I'll think about that one does
Black Panther kill yeah
Black Panther can kill when he
absolutely has to but he would much
rather not kill somebody who is Black
Panthers enemy Black Panthers enemy is
Klaw enemy historically speaking that
would be me Erik kill market does
Chadwick Boseman
have siblings yes you don't get to know
how many yeah in this in this show I'm
not telling you me to be more than yes
yes where is postman's
I'm from Anderson South Carolina does
Chadwick Boseman sing professionally no
all right around the house yes
see get on up he sings and he can really
say he's a badass a karaoke what high
school did Chadwick go to zoo I went to
TL Hanna high school does Chadwick
Boseman do his own stunts yeah I love
doing stunts I not do as much as I can
do mm-hmm
how do I meet Chadwick you can meet me
and you can meet me outside you can meet
me at the room at 10:30 p.m. on
Thursdays I'm always there see the table
number three does Chadwick Boseman
dance come on man no idea what zodiac
sign is Michael B Jordan I'm an Aquarius
February 9th what was Michael B Jordan
first movie first movie I was ever in
his movie called black and white a long
time ago first real movie some real
speaking rolls hardball Paramount
Pictures Bryan Robbins Keanu Reeves is
awesome who is Michael B Jordan father
and father is Michael Jordan Michael
Jordan is Michael B Jordan related so
Michael Jordan yeah technically I'm
related to Michael Jordan but not the
one I'm I'm sure that you're talking
about read this Michael Jordan play
basketball Michael B Jordan does play
basketball
I haven't played ball in a long time but
yeah I used to be pretty competitive at
that basketball it might be Jordan
getting knocked out while filming creak
Wow these are the type of questions okay
not technically not knocked out but I
definitely took a real punch to the face
it wasn't that fun what is Lupita
Nyong'o doing right now what makeup does
Lupita and young
you ah that's Lancome what language does
Lupita Nyong'o speak
yes which language is I speak English
Spanish Swahili mhm and Luo whoa
whinnies Lupino yah goes birthday it is
March first
really yes no one day I wake you so
where does the Peter yarn go live I live
in Brooklyn New York
what part nowhere you know what you
don't need to say no don't say
[Music]